- C'était tellement rapide
à ce que, d'une certaine façon,
que j'étais sur le bord
de tout perdre.
- François Girard a découver
en ligne en 2019.
FRANÇOIS GIRARD
- Ça a été pas mal la publicité,
je te dirais, sur Internet
ou quelque chose crs des sites
de jeux en ligne.
- Mais c'est en 2020,
lors de la première année
le fond le fond le fond le fond.
- Un manque de social, un manque
d'activités, avec plus de tempse
24 heures sur 24, bien,
si t'as plus de temps, bien,
- Il est loin d'être le seuldan.
Le nombre d'adultes québécois
qui jouent de l'ara grimpé de 7t
la pandémie; 1 Qué 5
s'adonne désormais à ce type
de jeux, et le qua
disent avoir dépassé les limites
qu'ils s'étaient fixées,
au point où certains développent
une dépe
traitée.
ANNE ELIZABETH LAPOINTE, dg
Maison Jean-Lapointe
la pandémie, on a vraiment vu
un 180 degrés, si je peux dire,
et maintenant, 80 % de
la clientèle s'adonne à des jeux
en ligne et c'est est aussi plus
risqué que les jeux au casino
ou dans les bars, qui ont été
Il est accessible en tout temps,
ux mineurs, et c'est
facile de jouer à crédit.
- Ça is de temps
que c'est devenu envahissant,
puis c'était que ça,
- François Girard a perdu près
de 50 000 $ en quelques mois.
- Des fois, je déposais juste
50 $, des fois, c'était just
100 $, mais je pouvais le faire
40 fois dans une journée.
plus qu'une fois.
- Notamment avec la carte
de crédit de sa conjointe
sans qu'
- J'étais sur le bord
de m'enlever la vie...
parce que je faisais du mal
à ma famille.
- En plus de créer
une dépendance, les jeux
auxquels jouait Frégaux au QuéÀ.
- Pourtant, leurs publicités
pullulent à la télé; mêmeconnues
s'y associent.
- On Bet99.net...
ANDRÉE-ANNE LEGARÉ, professeure
- Ces publicités-là
sont pros parce
qu'elles dirigent les joueurs
vers des sites de jeux qui ne
-Québec, donc qui
ne sont pas des sites de jeux
légaux au Québec.
- Un problème que connaît
la société d'État, impuissanteÇg
Loto-Québec- Loto-Québec ne peus
faire de plainte au criminel.
C'est pas... on n'a pas
au gouvernement fédéral
et aux instances de faire
appliquer son code criminel.
ces jeux sont prêtes à tout
pour garifs.
- J'ai même fermé
puis ils ont été capables
de me retrouver su,
je reçois ça sur message texte,
par la poste.
- Malgré leur insistance,
une thérapie de trois semaines
a permis à François Girard
de mettre fin à sa dépendance.